the Scandal that's rocking the car
industry the emissions cheating scandal
continues to get even more toxic
directly affects the era that people
breathe
these events and I fully agree on this
are deeply troubling
Volkswagen is one of the largest and the
most trusted Automotive brands in the
entire world not only do they own the
brand of Volkswagen but they also own
the Audi Porsche Lamborghini Bentley and
even Bugatti at one point but despite
their size Volkswagen it doesn't exactly
have the best of reputations especially
in recent years it seems that they're
ever growing size has simply allowed for
bureaucracy and politics to see Penny
and when these attributes are present
it's usually just a matter of time until
a company starts putting money over
morals and ethics this is exactly what
happened in the mid-2010s when
Regulators discovered that Volkswagen
was cheating at emissions tests and this
wasn't some sort of isolated incident
either Volkswagen had been cheating on
emissions tests for six years between
2009 and 2015 and their Antics had
affected half a million cars in the US
and another 10.5 million cars outside
the U.S after this came to light
Volkswagen was immediately fined a 14.7
billion dollars and this was just the
first of several settlements lawsuits
and criminal investigations by the end
of The Saga the emission Scandal caused
a Volkswagen a total of 31.3 billion
euros or little under 35 billion dollars
usually companies have a history of
getting away with relatively cheap fines
but this was clearly not one of those
scenarios not to mention the financial
loss wasn't even their biggest concern
nowadays people are acutely aware of the
importance of clean energy minimizing
pollution and protecting the Earth in
fact millions of people around the world
think that this is so important that
they're willing to shout out
substantially more money to buy an EV
over a gasoline vehicle so with this
type of History there's no question that
Volkswagen alienated a significant
portion of the market with these types
of consequences you would think that
companies would think twice before Aging
in such activities but given the
consistency of scandals amongst
corporate Giants this is clearly not the
case so here's how Volkswagen got caught
up in arguably the largest Automotive
Scandal ever and stained the reputation
permanently
while Volkswagen it didn't make
international headlines until the
emissions Scandal the company has very
much had a history of scandals but they
weren't always the culprit in fact at
one point Volkswagen was actually on the
other side of their father as a victim
back in March of 1987 Volkswagen would
announce that they had lost as much as
258 million dollars due to fraudulent
foreign exchange deals as an
international conglomerate Volkswagen
often deals with the dozens of
currencies and it's their responsibility
to proactively convert between these
currencies and hedge their reserves to
ensure that they don't lose money to
fluctuations in currency value in 1985
they animated one such routine hedge
against the US dollar but it turns out
that the person telling them the hedge
of force the documents fortunately for
Volkswagen it the FBI would eventually
arrest the suspect several months later
but unfortunately for everyone else this
was the last time that Volkswagen was on
the victim side of a scandal Volkswagen
didn't just instantly jump to
International schemes though as with the
most things Volkswagen's descent into
the darkness was much more gradual and
almost indiscernible and started off
with some misbehaving Executives who
were more interested in personal gain
take a closet walkert for example pause
it was the representative of
Volkswagen's 300 000 workers since the
early 1990s from the very beginning
workers weren't exactly a fan of claws
they felt that Clause was very much on
the side of leadership than the side of
the laborers but in reality it turns out
that the only team Claus was really on
was his own during his time at the top
claws would abuse his power to power to
3 million worth of illegal bonuses which
included 590 000 to a Brazilian lover
this earned claws convictions on 48
counts of inciting fraud along with the
two years and nine months in jail but
Claus was just one of many corrupt
leaders at Volkswagen another corrupt
leader was Peter Hartz unlike lost
though Peter actually had Ambitions
Beyond helping just himself he of course
did plenty of that too though he was
Notorious for using company fonts to pay
for escorts and certain types of parties
but more than that Peter had a history
of trying to bribe people he bribed
walks back in suppliers to make it seem
like he had one Volkswagen insanely
lucrative deals he also bribed the union
to make it seem like he had more worker
support than he really did the only
place all this led him though was facing
44 counts of breach of trust along with
the two-year prison sentence and that
these were just the most notable cases
some other Volkswagen representatives
were tricked in Indian State into paying
them a bunch of money for a factory that
was never built as you can see
Volkswagen was filled with these crony
leaders by the late 2000s but none of
these guys were truly The Dangerous Ones
the truly Dangerous Ones don't care
about winning money they care about
winning a reputation
Regulators were by no means looking for
an emission Scandal when they started
testing a Volkswagen cars they were
actually just conducting a boring old
study that was trying to identify the
emissions differences between European
cars and American cars and to accomplish
this they hired five scientists from
West Virginia University as scientists
these five set out to eliminated as many
variables as possible except for the
ones that were being studied one of the
variables that they eliminated was the
emissions testing system instead of
using systems provided by the
manufacturer they used the Japanese
emission testing system for all of the
vehicles and this is when they noticed
something alarming Volkswagen cars that
weren't just emitting more pollution
than they claimed but they were emitting
so much that they were breaking laws
take their Works back in Jetta for
example according to previous tests the
Jedi was only outputting 0.022 grams of
nitrogen oxide for every kilometer of
driving this was a well below the EPA
limit of 0.043 grams per kilometer her
it was basically half the limit but West
Virginia found that the Jedi was
actually emitting anywhere between 0.61
to 1.5 grams of nitrogen oxides for
every kilometer of driving even their
lowest reading was 14 times the
allowable limit while the highest
reading was 34 times the allowable limit
and a very similar story could be seen
with a bunch of other Volkswagen cars as
well when the researchers published
their findings the entire world was
shocked but there were more so puzzled
how was Volkswagen able to pass millions
of emission tests for years if they had
disgustingly High emissions they
couldn't just pay off a couple of
testers or give them special vehicles
because they weren't the only ones who
were conducting exams a substantial
number of states in the U.S required
that car owners get their vehicle
emission certified on a regular basis so
this wasn't just a matter of taking
tests a handful of times this was a
matter of consistently faking hundreds
of thousands if not millions of exams so
so how did the Volkswagen manage to pull
this off for years well it turns out
that clever engineering can easily
bypass exams conducted by poorly funded
regulatory bodies what the Volkswagen
had done was install special emission
software onto 11 million cars around the
world this software was capable of
detecting when routine emissions exams
were being conducted and it would change
a whole bunch of variables to reduce
emissions
change things like fuel pressure
injection timing exhaust gas
recirculation and the amount of urea
sprayed into the exhaust while this was
extremely clever all you really had to
do to find the real emissions was use
next to a testing device that wouldn't
set off Volkswagen systems but somehow
regulatory bodies had failed to do this
for six years
one of the biggest questions that you
might have is why didn't Volkswagen just
set their cars to always be in this mode
they were clearly able to pass emissions
exams with the flying colors using the
software so why not use it all the time
well the problem was that this would
severely limit the power and speed of
their vehicles their cars wouldn't be
able to hit the promise to 0-60 numbers
or horsepower and the torque numbers if
you're not into cars this probably seems
like a non-issue but it walks back and
felt that reducing these numbers would
go against their brand image and appeal
here's the thing the people buying
German cars aren't looking for something
economical or environmental if they were
they would just buy a Japanese car
rather people buy German cars for three
reasons luxury social status and raw
power this is why Audi owners are
willing to deal with more expensive
maintenance bills and a lower
reliability if you substantially reduce
the power of these vehicles however much
fewer people would be willing to deal
with associated headaches and many of
them would likely buy a Mercedes or BMW
instead with that being said though it
and it probably would have been a better
idea for Volkswagen to just spend more
time figuring out how to minimize
emissions while maximizing power instead
of Faking exams but that would be too
logical anyway Volkswagen would
eventually admit installing the secret
software and that they would agree to
buy back cars from owners at a pretty
generous price owners not only received
the pre-scandled trade-in value of their
cars but they also received a five to
ten thousand dollars in additional
compensation Volkswagen also agreed to
spend a 4.7 billion dollars on programs
looking to offset emissions and the
Boost to clean vehicle projects so
financially speaking the public actually
came out pretty well but the CMA cannot
be said about pollution and health
concerns Volkswagen literally had over
10 million cars on the road for years
meeting up to 40 times the legal amount
and these limits aren't in place just
for fun extremely Intel scientists have
determined that Vehicles emitting more
than a certain amount are more of a
detriment Society than a benefit and
we're not just talking about climate
change or melting polar caps we're
talking about lung cancer and lots of it
in the European Union for example 20 of
urban populations are subject to
hazardous nitrogen dioxide
concentrations and 40 percent of all
nitrogen oxide emissions in London come
from diesel road traffic every year 3
000 people die due to air pollution in
London alone so who knows how many
people walks back into high emissions
truly affected it and potentially even
killed
foreign
the worst part about all of this is that
Volkswagen wasn't the only one that was
guilty of Faking exams after the news
broke about Volkswagen Regulators
started looking into all cars more
closely and they quickly realized that a
lot of cars had much better readings and
exams than on the road on the bright
side this has prompted Regulators to
tighten their testing procedures but the
real solution is of course EVs and it
looks like Volkswagen is working very
hard to redeem themselves and under
earned back public trust while
Volkswagen had some doubts about
pivoting to EVS in the early days more
recently they've basically completely
committed to the switch more than half
of all of Volkswagen's budget over the
next five years is going towards EVS
which works out to 100 billion dollars
they're pouring insane amounts into
battery research building new factories
and most importantly scaling up
production they're hoping that by 2026 a
quarter of all the vehicles they sell
will be electric and given that
Volkswagen regularly sells 10 million
cars per year that works out to well
above 2 million EVS at this rate some
experts say that Volkswagen may even
overtake Tesla in terms of EV deliveries
but we'll just have to wait and see it
do you think Volkswagen can redeem
themselves by pushing forward the EV
Revolution comment that down below also
drop a like if you're glad that more
companies are embracing EVs and of
course consider checking out our Discord
Community suggested video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered until then
I'm Ari and I'll see you guys on the
next one
foreign